I would like to reveal something what  she fake ate my ass  for real the other girl's giving me head  and she just decides to get back there  and I don't know she smelled something  my ass she was licking the area  immediately above it and afterwards I  just called her out in the car like what  was that okay yes please really really  big butt cheeks okay what I'm supposed  to open the curtains and put and put  whole face in it like yes you need to  bend over  I keep wanting him to let me eat his ass  in different positions but he doesn't  like feeling feminine so he won't like  bend over but like that's better  you're just getting some head she's  getting it real real sloppy the spit is  dripping down so she can't taste the  fecal matter on your butthole and then  oh slowly your legs just kind of go up  it gets deeper in there you know  Cannonball  [Laughter]